من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي عميد الياس اهلا بك نبدا
بمنظومه باتريو 30 وصلت اخيرا الى قرار
امريكي بتسليمها لاوكرانيا وان كانت
منظومه واحده كيف تقرا هذا التطور الان
على الساحه العسكري
مياده اولا على الساحه العسكريه هي تحول
ولكن هذا السلاح لا يزال سلاح دفاعي بعكس
ما يطلبه اكثر الرئيس الامريكي ان يحافظ
على المومنتم على الاندفاعها التي حقق
فيها في خرسان وفي حتى في حركان تاتي هذه
الزياره الى واشنطن على المستوى السياسي
الاعلى بارتباط امريكا
بمساعده اوكرانيا وبالتالي الانتقال الى
مرحله مختلفه لانه المعركه تتطلب دفاعات
جويه بسبب القصف الاستراتيجي على كل
البناء التحتيه وهنا تكتمل صوره الدفاعات
الجويه يعني من
الصواريخ التي تطلق عن الكتف من فات كما
يقال عنها الى صواريخ البوك الروسيه او من
صنع السلاسيه الى الاس-300 الى نسام
النرويجيه الى همم الايريس الالمانيه
وياتي الباتريوت ليكمل هذه معزومه اذا
اكتملت فعلا هذه المنظومه قد يصبح تقريبا
الدفاعات الجويه مهمه على الساحه
الاوكرانيه وهي ما تعاني منه حاليا
لكن
مقاله المسؤول الامريكي للجزيره انها
بطاريه واحده
البطاريه واحده يمكن ان تحدث فارفا
بطاريه صواريخ واحده بطاريه واحده
اتمنى
صواريخ احنا تحدث عن اثنين وثلاثين صاروخ
قد يتم الاهتمام بمنطقه معينه حولك كيف
على سبيل المثال وليس بالضروره على كل
اوكرانيا يعني اليوم هذه البطاريه فعلا لا
تكفي ولكنها عام المغير قد تحميم منطقه
مهمه جدا خاصه كما قلت العاصمه كياب هذه
لم تصل هذه ايضا الى اوكرانيا بعد هي
عمليه تدريب يعني
قد تاخذ عده اشهر وهي بحاجه الى 90 الى
100 من 90 الى 100 جندي ذات كفاءه عاليه
لتشغيل عليها في المقابل الجانب الروسي
دفع ايضا بالصواريخ صار مات وسيركون في
مقابل الباتريوت هل هنا هو محاوله لموازنه
همم الميدان الع
مياده ان نتحدث عن زينكون عن سرمات عن
كنجال هذه صواريخ زاد بعد جي واستراتيجي
كبير جدا وهي رساله ليست لاوكرانيا لانه
لا يمكن المقارنه بين الباتريوت وهذه
الصواريخ التي تحمل رؤوس نوويه هي رساله
ردعيه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي
تسكير وهي عمليه الانتقال من مرحله
التجارب لهذه الصواريخ الى مرحله نشرها
وتزويد الجيش الروسي فيها ونحن في عمليه
شد حبال او عد اصابعي في هذه المرحله
بيروت